hey everyone it's Mike from oros here
and welcome back to my channel I'm glad
you can join me for this video I'm going
be talking about again you know sort of
the difference differences between a
range based chart and a Time based chart
because you know I was posting a video
up the uh yesterday or the day before
and you know it sparked a bit of
discussion in the comment section um you
know cuz I used in the video an eight
range chart and you know if you've
watched some of my videos from several
years ago you know I I was using range
based charts and instead of time based
charts where was more recently I've been
on um time based charts so at the end of
the day honestly it doesn't matter what
chart you use the whole point of
choosing a chart to look at is to make
the market easier for you to understand
okay and today is a is a great example
of you know settling on i w say I don't
like using that word settling on the
chart but sort of deciding on the chart
type that you're going to use going
forward okay and in the snps here um you
know we had a low at 4515 in at uh you
know 1150 basically this is a eight
range chart and again whether you're
using an eight range chart a 10 range
chart um it's up for you to decide right
I know some people that like to use you
know very short range charts you know
four Range Five range charts um you have
to sort of decide how you want to
approach the market what your you know
your your risk tolerance is you know can
you accept you know quick moves going
against you um you know where you're
going to be placing your stop things
like that okay so that all comes into
choosing the type of chart basically it
just comes down to comfortability okay
you don't want to be getting into a
trade and getting stopped out too soon
right you want to be looking at a chart
that you could see the market develop
and be comfortable with but on this low
of the day here okay now we got negative
Delta minus 83 okay we got a bullish
Prominent Point of control all right and
then five bars later we got multiple
imbalances that's this green box around
the bar okay the bar right off the low
after right after the low it's got a
strong Delta into volume um 25% right
that's why it's called it
magenta whereas if you're on a Time
based chart it looks completely
different you still have that low at
1150 but you don't have a bullish
Prominent Point of control and you know
you don't have a strong Delta coming in
Delta into volume it's just 14% you
still got this uh strong negative 1
minus 26% here right here is-
25% um you know and a few bars later
then you see the aggressive buying
coming in here 32 Delta into volume
right it's the magenta color you got 1 2
3 4 5 buying imbalances right and the
market starts working its way up now
again
there's bullish things happening here in
the order flow in this bar at 1156 if
you're on a range based chart right you
got the bullish Prominent Point of
control right you've got the next bar
with the bullish Delta into the volume
here you've got um you know the multiple
imbalances you also got a strong bullish
Delta into volume okay so this low even
though it's the exact same low
4515 the way it's forming on a range
based chart is different now that's you
know so if if you're using a range based
chart you know you could have been
picking up on this low maybe a little
bit sooner than if you're on a timebase
chart okay so at the end of the day it
basically comes down to what type of
Market you're trading and you know what
makes sense to you as a Trader you know
for
example uh okay you know I talk about
the bond market a lot right bonds is is
a market that I strictly
use range-based charts on I can't use a
Time based chart I I don't want to go
out can't use a one minute chart right
this
is show you a a one minute chart in the
bonds it looks like this for me
that's it's hard for me to make a
trading decision based off of the
information where it's basically trading
one price and you know maybe ticks one
tick above or one tick below okay so I I
can't make anything out of that that's
not useful to me I could go to you know
a longer time frame maybe 5 minutes um
you know I could get some decent useful
information on a f minute
chart
okay but I I just find it for me as you
know as a person I find it easier for me
to look at a range based chart on a
slower moving Market because I know that
the chart is forming
based off of price movements okay and
you know whether it comes down to also
doesn't matter which chart you're
looking at range based tick based volume
based time based you're still going to
be looking for the same things in the
order flow so on this four range chart I
got exhaustion print right here I got
exhaustion print right here right this
one's at 750 this one here is at
843 okay got a zero print in here got
multiple buying and balances stack
buying and balances actually in this bar
so I'm
not you know concerned with having to
flip through different charts you you
you decide on what chart you're going to
look at and you stick with it until
reading the market off of that becomes a
bit more of a struggle for you in the
sense you know sometimes you know some
markets volatility picks up right we saw
that if you remember in when you know
the world shut down because of coid
right remember the markets were going
nutso and you know I knew people that
were trading range-based charts in
markets like
ym you know they're using 10 range
charts 15 range charts next thing I know
I'm talking to them guy's on a 50 range
chart right just because of the movement
right and but
that's um you know he had to make that
adjustment and as a Trader right just
because you decide what type of chart
you're looking at you're not pigeon hold
for the rest of your trading career into
that chart because again if you've
watched my videos over time right in
2016 2017 you know I've been trading
with you know more range based charts
but over the last couple years I've been
on more time based charts now again you
know you maybe you know 5 minutes is not
good enough for you maybe you want to go
to a little bit shorter time frame but
not a one minute chart you know people
use three minute charts they use uh two
minute charts you know the story of guys
you know when they left the
floor you know when you're on the floor
right you don't I mean back this is back
in the 90s right they don't have charts
that they could just easily uh pull up
while on the floor because you know back
in those days they didn't have I mean
you had laptops but you little one stood
in the pit at that time with a laptop
but guys that would leave the
floor you know all of a sudden they're
trying all these different time frames 2
minutes 3 minutes
and made me laugh is this I forgot who
it was was telling the story about how
you know he was using a three minute
chart thinking he's going to have an
edge over the people trading a 5minute
chart okay still the same data it's just
formatted differently because you're on
a different type of chart um you know
this is a three minute chart okay maybe
you don't want to use a three minute
chart maybe you want to use a 4minute
chart okay and again you know I get
emails from people asking how the market
looks you know on a footprint on a
3-minute chart well or a 4minute chart
well this is a 4-minute chart now you're
starting to get some price movements um
you know again you know even me I got
you know it broken down you know I do
look at I don't have it on here my
testing computer I even got a 90c chart
a minute and a half right it's people
got all sorts of uh all sorts of time
frames and and things that they look at
right I
2584 uh tick chart right because you
know sometimes get questions and of a
Trader that follows this type of chart
and he wants to know how water flow
looks on it okay it's still the same
information but it's just formatted
differently because it's based off of
your amount of Tex or the amount of
volume or the amount of time
okay and again you know you're still
going to
get that one contract off you know here
whether I was on a you know this is a
2480 thck chart if I was on a know what
this is 15 minute chart right I still
got that one down there um you know some
of the times these things just really
stick out in the order flow okay if I
was on a FIV minute chart I showed you
that already but um you know if I'm on
a volume based chart I don't know
10,000 okay now it's lumped in with that
other one from happened a little bit
around that time you know it's two
there sorry where am I no here it is I I
was looking at yesterday that's
yesterday's this is today there's still
that
one you see on a 10,000 volume chart if
you're looking at exhaustion prints you
know one up here one down here seven or
two this is it's not highlighting here
because this is a dogee candle on a
10,000 volume
chart um you that's why sometimes I see
people you know the these you know these
price action traders that think that
they're orderflow Traders um I'm not
going to name their names but uh you
know try to keep it positive because
it's it's Traders like that that you
know help us out because when we
actually read the orderflow actual
volume you it kills me I see a lot of
Traders posting stuff on Twitter on
Facebook oh yeah we got barish order
flow then they're showing a simple bar
chart well how you know it's one thing
to say well I got a green candle so I
got both order flow well no kidding
right got red candle I got bearish order
flow yeah you got bearish price action
or bullish price action but you don't
know the actual volumes that going
through but um you know when when I see
people say well yeah I'm going to start
with a 4-Hour chart and go down to 1
hour 15
minute you want to see this as early as
possible all right that's why I don't
really go out Beyond a 5 minute chart on
the order flow because by then you you
know if I'm looking at a hourly chart
and and this happened at 750 and you
know I'm looking at an hourly chart I'm
waiting for things to confirm you know
by 8:00 you know I've had some there's a
lot of movement in between that I could
have taken advantage of right I mean
people if you're really a true orderflow
Trader in my opinion you're more on the
short-term trading than the longer term
trading so anyway guys you know that was
sort of my rant about uh range versus
tick or tick range based charts versus
time based
charts doesn't matter at the end of the
day you know don't sit there you know
okay on this day you know Michael was
analyzing a four range chart it looked
pretty good okay really what you got to
do is is you got to experience it right
follow the market looking at a range
based chart follow the market looking at
a time based chart what makes it easier
for you to understand the Dynamics of
what's actually happening in the buying
and selling where volume is you know
accumulating or being distributed or not
even trading okay that's the chart that
you want where it just you you'll see
it's going to click right the light bul
will just go off and say this is the
chart for me you know I I completely
understand what's happening in the
market and you know sometimes it's going
to be a range-based chart for other
Traders it's going to be a time based
chart you know they want to know right
if you're looking at a a range based
chart you know that if you move a
certain amount of tix a new bar is going
to form okay so you could sort of figure
that okay you know like right here right
okay yeah if we we break above 29 be
bullish if we break below 20 you know 6
and 3/4 it would be bearish whereas on
timebase chart you know you could even
have a little clock on the bottom like I
got here is showing how much time has
left before the bar closes and the next
one
forms okay
so again at the end of the day it's you
got to figure out which chart is best
for you and your own trading that's part
of the trading Journey all right
everyone again I I go off on these rants
sometimes but you know it's one of those
things that you it's important because
the chart is you know is how you're
making your money right so you want to
be able to look at a chart that you
understand right you can't look at you
know a chart and if if you don't
understand what's happening what's the
point of looking at that chart okay so
like on time based chart yeah I got a
thin print here I got one
right I can just draw that line there so
okay yeah this is a a area of interest
to me if this Market you know we're
selling off maybe we come back up to
that
level and we could come away from it
right we come right back to 28 half we
trade it back down to
27 right so again you know what you're
going to do right if you have my
software you go through some of the
tools and you're going to add and you
know put things on there right you're
going to take things off that's going to
help you understand what's happening in
the market better right all right guys
I'll end it there thanks for suffering
with me um catch you on the next video
bye-bye